we're also living at a time where
everyone is looking for sale and
automation which means scale but not
debt the last 20 years it seemingly
looked like the people that had the
advantages were the ones that invested
in Automation and scale and technology
and that's what we saw happen what's
happening now is because the cat is out
of the bag and everybody understands
that that starts to over time become the
commodity and the advantage becomes the
things that are not automated that are
not Technology based they're a human
based this will be accelerated
dramatically with AI dramatically soon
everybody's white paper or presentations
are going to look the same because
they're all going to use the same
technology but the inputs from the human
level become the variable